welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead season 11 Parts 1 and 2
leading up to part three the final eight
episodes season 10 ended on a
cliffhanger when Eugene and his crew
were ambushed by the Stormtrooper
looking guys now we learn they're from
the Commonwealth it is a massive
successful survivors community that
seems to be a nice happy place now
remember the reason Eugene came here is
for a booty call with Stephanie His
Radio girlfriend who turns out is real
she wasn't catfishing him but the
arguably more important reason they came
here is to get help for Alexandria it's
in pretty bad shape remember the
whisperers trashed it last season and
the most urgent problem they're running
out of food which is becoming more and
more difficult to scavenge but now
Maggie is back on the show and she's
like hey the settlement I just came from
had a ton of food unfortunately it was
taken over by the Reapers they're a
scary group that came out of nowhere
like ghosts but Maggie's like hey I
ain't afraid of no ghosts so we'll all
roll up together and take them out so
the group sets off on a mission and
coming with them is Big Bad Negan he's
been on a Redemption Arc the last few
seasons but Maggie hasn't seen that and
is still real mad at him for killing her
husband Glenn when some Walkers show up
Maggie and Negan are the last two
climbing up this train and Maggie needs
a help in hand this could be a great
opportunity for Negan to earn her trust
by Saving her but he decides to go the
other way with it oh leaves are to fall
Mufasa at her but Maggie's not dying
that easy she manages to rejoin the
group and negan's like hey no hard
feelings you would have done the same
thing to me and there's no time to argue
because more Walkers coming for him Matt
he's got no choice but to work with him
to survive but it's Daryl who's the MVP
here rolling up on these zombies John
Wick style taking them all out but the
Danger's not over cause now they're
ambushed by the Reapers our group is all
separated naturally Negan and Maggie end
up together but luckily father Gabriel
shows up to mediate along with Maggie's
one surviving friend Elijah who is the
cool guy in the mask with the ninja
skills but he's not a Mandalorian who
has to keep his mask on he takes it off
instantly like Oh I'm a normal dude
meanwhile Daryl is separated looking for
his best friend dog who has been picked
up by a Reaper oh you don't want to mess
with John Wick's dog but turns out Daryl
knows this Reaper because it's Leah yeah
remember from the season 10 bonus
episode she was Daryl's girlfriend and
dog's original owner she takes him back
to the reaper compound turns out the
Reapers were her original crew they were
all soldiers together and then
mercenaries before the apocalypse
Daryl's like hey babe that's cool I
didn't even know those guys so I'll join
you so they give him the reaper entrance
exam and Daryl passes so he gets to meet
the leader of the Reapers Pope as you
might expect he is a psycho megalomaniac
who believes the Reapers were chosen by
God why is it so hard to meet normal
people in the zombie apocalypse then
there's a really memorable episode
featuring Connie who made it out of the
mines last season and met up with Virgil
the guy Michelle met The Walking Dead
goes full horror for an episode when
they take shelter in this haunted house
and thou are chased by these creepy
crawling zombies but wait those aren't
zombies these are living people that
have just gone full feral and turned
into Gollum from Lord of the Rings they
managed to escape and just then Connie's
sister Kelly shows up she's been
searching for her and now sisters
reunited now back to the Commonwealth
Stephanie agrees to help sneak him into
the radio tower so they can contact back
home but they gotta watch out for the
orange power ranger chief of security
Mercer it's princess who takes point
attracting him basically by hitting on
him but that doesn't distract him for
long they're caught and in big trouble
their lawyer is Lance Hornsby who is
basically exactly Better Call Saul and
he gets him off with just community
service clearing out Walker duty but
they don't get a thank you instead this
kid's like Mary you ruined my picnic and
he goes too far when he insults
Stephanie Eugene clocks this kid in the
face but this is a much bigger deal than
Eugene realized it seems like the
Commonwealth has a very strict class
system now back to Maggie's Mission
which is down to just four people
negan's like hey I have an idea to get
reinforcements from the Walkers oh
Whisperer style Maggie and Negan the new
Alpha and beta they assault the reaper
compound it's an epic finale so now it's
time to reveal himself hey sorry girl
but I'm with them the Reapers suck you
should join us Lee is conflicted what's
she gonna do but just then Pope unveils
the reaper secret weapon oh it's a
medieval rocket-propelled Arrow launcher
but Leah's like whoa if you fire this
thing you'll hit our brothers who are
down in the mixed fighting and Pope's
like hey if that's God's will then
that's what it is so now it's time for
the Daryl Pope Showdown but it's
actually Leah oh who gets me in the back
Daryl's like awesome I'm glad you joined
the light side but Leah's not joining
him she's like Pope had to go but the
reapers are still my brothers I'm
sticking with him oh she pulls a kylo
ren killed snoke but staying on the dark
side the Reapers fall back wait did we
win no you did not kylo Leah's just
pulled him back so she can fire the
huacha but you know none of our
characters get hit long story short we
fight to a stalemate with just a few
members on each side Leah calls in her
sniper on the roof but that's not her
man it's father Gabriel who went in for
the priest fight with the Reaper's guy
and took him out Daryl channels his
inner Rick Grimes the living are all on
the same side and Maggie agrees to let
him go but then Maggie remembers how
they slaughtered her entire community so
she changes her mind and kills the
remaining Reapers no mercy Leah escapes
when Daryl lets her go but operation
food run is a huge success except almost
everyone who came died including Alden
by the way R.I.P Alden as for Maggie and
negan's negan's like look mags this
group apparently isn't big enough for
both of us all just be on my way and
Negan leaves the group back at
Alexandria things have been rough
they're barely holding it together but
now our crew's back and for the first
time this season everyone's reunited
including our couples like Daryl and
Connie who have a fun flirtation going
and father Gabriel and Rosita who I
constantly forget are dating but wait
what's this who's coming now a bunch of
Stormtroopers yes Eugene finally talked
to the Commonwealth about helping
Alexandria and now Lance hornsby's like
hey uh this place has seen better days
we're happy to help you rebuild but also
anyone who wants can come join us in the
Commonwealth we're immediately teased
with a six-month time Jump where
Maggie's back at Hilltop facing off
against Stormtrooper Daryl how did we
get here we go back to just a one month
time Jump where a lot of our crew are
settled in at the Commonwealth which
truly does seem to be a good place it's
a survivors community on a level we've
never seen before apparently they've got
50 000 people it's a real City the
leader of the Commonwealth is Governor
Pamela Milton who seems like a nice
person but our crew doesn't have the
best track record with Governors
everyone's assigned to jobs based on
what they were before the zombie
apocalypse Daryl and Rosita didn't
really have jobs before so they joined
the military their skills are killing
Walkers Daryl gets on the bad side of
the incomparable douche that is the
governor's son Sebastian Milton normally
Daryl wouldn't put up with this he'd
just go off and live as a Woods hermit
again but with Rick and Michonne both
off the show Daryl's taking in their
kids Judith and RJ so he needs that
Stormtrooper money to provide for his
family and that is the secretly devious
part of the Commonwealth they're not
cannibals they just use money and
they've got a massive wealth gap between
the Haves and have-nots yumiko who was a
fancy Harvard lawyer gets to come to
fancy parties while her girlfriend
Magnus serving the drinks anyone who
stands up like we are the 99 gets
immediately shut down to Pamela Milton
they're more dangerous than the zombies
but for the most part life in the
Commonwealth is really good especially
for Eugene with his lady loves Stephanie
things are going great between them
until one day she ghosts him out of
nowhere and Eugene can't believe he's
been dumped he thinks it's much more
likely it's a vast government conspiracy
and turns out he's absolutely correct
this is not Stephanie in fact she
doesn't even wear glasses she's just an
agent working for her boss Lance Hornsby
who is in charge of the Commonwealth CIA
you put her undercover to learn this
group's Secrets but turns out they don't
really have any so hey bro sorry we
broke your heart but just as Eugene's
feeling real bad he hears a familiar
voice that knows his and Stephanie's
radio call signs turns out this is the
real Stephanie she's Pamela Milton's
assistant we've seen a few times
although Stephanie was still a fake name
her name is Max but everything else was
real she built a secret radio and really
liked Eugene but having a secret radio
was very illegal so Mercer her brother
kept her out of trouble by setting him
up with the fake Stephanie thing she's
like bro how could you not know that
wasn't me but he's like hey a hot girl
liked me I wasn't gonna ask questions
and so these two work it out and truly
fall in love speaking of romance
princess continues hitting on Mercer and
he's into it these two start dating
meanwhile Carol has put back on her Meek
housewife cookie baking persona but
she's watching everything real close her
ex King Ezekiel remember has cancer and
she does some snooping finds he's way
down the list so she goes to Lance
Hornsby like hey I can do a lot more
than big cookies she helps him out with
an off the book CIA Mission and he gets
Ezekiel moved up the list for surgery
and hey he's cancer-free now back at
Alexandria where Aaron is the leader
these days and the Commonwealth really
is helping rebuild but Maggie has gone
back to Hilltop and they're offering to
help her too but she turns him down she
sees right through the Commonwealth's
class system BS and wants no part of it
Pamela Milton could care less like let
him keep their little wooden for it but
Lance Hornsby really wanted to make this
deal happen because theoretically if the
Commonwealth has colonies he could
become the regional governor and now we
start to see Lance hornsby's crazy side
oh we thought he was Saul Goodman looks
like he's little finger so one day Aaron
and Gabriel are recruited for an
Outreach mission to this community that
lives in an apartment building it's like
hey guys the Commonwealth's real cool we
have ice cream and stuff but oh their
boss starts shooting people up yeah the
Outreach mission was just a cover for an
extermination Mission so as this guy
starts executing civilians Aaron and
Gabriel take a stand against it now
they're under arrest but they're rescued
by none other than Negan yes this is
where he wandered off to it's only been
six months but Negan has a girlfriend
here in fact they're married in fact
she's pregnant my man Negan moves quick
long story short he gets a message to
Maggie so she comes to join the
apartment resistance but her son
Herschel stowed away and now he's
captured by the Commonwealth so uncle
negan's got a bus down there to save him
now I call him Uncle Negan these days
but you gotta remember he was a monster
who brutally murdered herschel's father
but he finally shows some real remorse
like Hey kid I'm sorry I'm not that guy
anymore so they put this beef on hold so
working together Our Gang takes these
Commonwealth soldiers out and this guy
Carlson ends up eaten by the people he
pushed off the building back at the
Commonwealth Daryl's playing nice with
Sebastian Milton so one day he takes him
out for an off the books Mission he
wants them to break into the zombie
infested house where his friend used to
live and he knows his dad had a bunch of
cash in the safe yeah remember the
Commonwealth uses American currency so
cash is still King but turns out they're
not the first people Sebastian sent he
sent a bunch of random civilians who are
deep in debt and desperate and that goes
beyond off the book's mission for
Commonwealth soldiers he's fully just
sending poor people to their dads Mercer
followed him here they explained the
situation he doesn't confront Sebastian
and start a whole thing but he's now
disillusioned with Commonwealth
leadership but the rest of our crew is
ready to expose it along with reporters
Connie and Kelly who have already been
working to expose Commonwealth
corruption what they need is some hard
evidence and Eugene knows someone who
can help his girlfriend Max Pamela
Milton's assistant who has also become
disillusioned realized Pamela Milton
only cares about money so max Mercer
goes to her brother Mike Mercer like hey
you're the Commonwealth's poster boy
it's time you stand up for what's right
and Max steal some files that don't
reveal every thing there's still some
deeper conspiracy we don't understand
but it's enough to print an Expose and
the start of the Commonwealth revolution
has started but meanwhile Lance Hornsby
goes in person to find out what happened
at the apartment where Aaron and Gabriel
play it cool with a cover story he knows
they're lying though and suspects that
Maggie at the hilltop was involved and
so this is where we get the standoff
Maggie versus Stormtrooper Daryl but
when tensions get high Daryl proves he's
on Maggie's side and Lance is like whoa
I don't want to fight we'll leave you in
peace but on the way back it becomes
apparent that our crew's been Marked for
Death so oh it turns into one Epic
shootout Maggie knows Lance is coming
for her so she needs a babysitter brings
Herschel to Uncle Negan and these two
finally have a breakthrough Maggie's
like look Negan I'm never gonna forgive
you for Glenn but after everything we've
been through now I trust you so Maggie
takes the fight to the Commonwealth
soldiers but she's ambushed and captured
by Reaper Leah yes Lance Hornsby found
her hanging around like hey wait you
want Maggie dead I want Maggie dead
let's work together and so it's the
final Maggie Leah fight in the end Leah
has the upper hand but oh she's shot by
Daryl yes who chose his best friend
Maggie over his ex-girlfriend Leah Lance
hornsby's rolling up with some
Stormtroopers but Daryl takes a shot and
oh grazes his cheek and so our crew
escapes for now but Lance Hornsby is not
happy he decides to occupy Hilltop fly
in the Commonwealth flag and he occupies
Alexandria too no more foreign aid
you're now a commonwealth colony and
don't forget Oceanside is our third big
Community Lance Hornsby rounds everyone
up and flips his lucky coin oh man is he
turning into a two-face would he execute
all of Oceanside find out in the final
eight episodes of The Walking Dead
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]